يعمل وجدي بوزيان مشرفا عاما على الاشغال
باحدى الشركات المقاولات منذ 14 سنه يؤكد
ان وضعته الماديه صعبه رغم انه اطار ثامن
وانه لم يعد قادرا على مجابهات متطلبات
عائلته رغم ان زوجته تشتغل ايضا
في الحقيقه اليوم نعيش في وضع برشا رغم
اني انا اثار في شركه ومرتي اطار في شركه
لكن المقدر شراء
طبقه الوسطى من التونسيين لتتعقد المساله
اكثر لدى محدوديه الدخل من الاجراء
الاتحاد سيواصل مسار التعبئه من اجل
الدفاع عن المرفق العمومي ولا من اجل
الدفاع عن خدمات اللائقه التونسيين اليوم
لا يمكن الاستمرار بهذا النهج نهج
اللامبالاه تجاهها غرق وافلاس المؤسسات
العموميه
اتحاد الشغل المركزيه النقابيه عدل بوصلته
وعلى مطالب الاجراء واتهم امينه العام
الحكومه بالتحايل وبالسعي الى بيع البلاد
عبر خصخصه مؤسساتها العموميه
وتؤكد الحكومه انها لم ترفع الدعم وانما
ستواجهه الى مستحقيها وانها لن تبيع
المؤسسات العموميه بل ستعيدها هيكلتها
لانقاذها من الازمه الماليه لكن الخبراء
ايوكدونا ان الحلول امام الحكومه تكاد
تكون منعدمه وعليها تنشيط الدبلوماسيه
الاقتصاديه لانقاذ اقتصاد البلاد
لابد من الاشاره الى انه الدبلوماسي
الاقتصاديه النشيطه في المجال الاقتصادي
التي توجه كل المجادات لتعبئه موارد ماليه
خارجيه سواء كان من قطر الليبي الشقيق او
من بعض الدول الخليجيه الشقيقه هذا التوجه
لابد ان ينطلقوا بسرعه في كل الحالات
وتعيشوا البلاد ازمه ماليه خانقه تسببت في
ارتفاع نسبه التضخم الى 9.2% مع فقدان
المواد الاستهلاكيه الاساسيه من الاسواق
ما ينظر بازمه اجتماعيه
تؤكد وتحركات الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
ومواقف قياداته الاخيره على قطاع الحوار
مع الحكومه وضعنا يجمع المراقبون على انه
مؤشر على نظير معركه اجتماعيه قد تجعل
شتاء هذا العام الاكثر سخونه في ظل غيابها
مش المناوره امام السلطات من اجل تعبئه
موارد الميزانيه وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس